[Music]
so beth is standing at the washing
station watching this bloody body part
which she then throws away she turns
back to the water to
wash the blood off her gloves but why
wash your gloves at all when
one you're just gonna throw them away
and two you should be washing your hands
okay but we've been here for hours i i
don't want to hang out at the stupid
horse hospital
kids what's this thing that's a breeding
mount how are you communicating so
clearly with someone who has departed
the room entirely
and if the walls are so thin how does
beth not hear morty flip on the bang
bang ba-doop-bop machine
i can't believe i'm gonna ask this
question but since we find out soon
morty is going to
[ __ ] the bojacker how exactly does he
get his morty junior into it he's
practically at eye level with the entry
point
drinking directly from the carton while
on a lawn chair sitting on a slanted
roof
come on yeah because rolling a barrel a
horse even from the street is much
easier than backing up the station wagon
to the garage
reading from a great distance away you
know that race of underground dwelling
cannibal horse people that we're always
fighting yeah the chuds
what about you can't just take an
acronym that has already situated itself
in previous pop culture and make it your
own
and how would the acronym even work in
this form cannibalistic horse
underground dwellers it doesn't roll off
the tongue in a meaningful or fun way
kahud might be a terrible movie but it
got here first oh so what the [ __ ] is up
with the security
at this horse hospital no one here finds
out a kid is mounting the horse juicer
why don't you trust labels all right
fine i won't test it
wait what since when does rick given to
morty's hysterics
or even trust labels goddamn your
generation really picks random hills to
die
on zoomers can you give me a minute i'm
trying to steer around the bodies of our
neighbors
oh that felt like gene knowing your
neighbors by the sound their body makes
when you run over them
space sperm sperm from space is anything
a stretch for the smith family they've
seen countless unexplainable things up
to this point so this newest shenanigan
should end in a casual shrug
this is the greatest country on earth it
is not don't blame me
i'm just quoting jeff daniels hello
hello sorry i'm late oh
look a fumbling disheveled an awkward
scientist cliche meat
how do we deal with these or gaza
goblins who's gonna tell the writers
that sperm and orgasms are not
synonymous
just because he oomphs doesn't mean she
zooms it's a fine suggestion but i doubt
their leader will be a sexy queen that
needs to be kickboxed
sexy sperm queen foreshadowing says
queen shadowing scream zigzag
rick and morty survive this i know
you're getting dumber because that's a
trebuchet
i guess the show has time to discuss the
difference between a trebuchet and a
catapult but
not concern itself about the giant hole
in the aircraft right to the top
just the way you like it except the
water isn't
to the top get this guy a nobel prize
you became a woman today yeah that
i checks so wrong about this guy he
didn't even buy us any time well maybe
run away instead of watching someone
attempt to be both the six and the nine
the stalling is really on you rick
silence in the presence of me
i am the sperm queen i don't even need
to question this one
title of my sex tape in fact a lot of
dialogue could fall under many of my
titles
space sperm sperm from space damn they
must be huge
why would the sperm go to the grand
canyon we'll use it as a placeholder and
beat it later
right to the top just the way you like
it i i know how to
myself you need more than that dummy you
need a horse hand job solo
how did dan harmon get a hold of my
stash i don't know whether to be ashamed
or overjoyed
why do you have the horse jerk-off
machine for my daughter's hospital it's
kind of weird that rick knows for
certain this breeding machine is the one
in beth's workplace no
oh but our stallion is already here i
get that morty created all of them in
the first place but do they really need
morty to continue their race
every spermable person could be eligible
for this very disgusting
highly sticky nightmare-inducing
situation that i'm totally not signing
up for a chance to experience myself
what was it like fantastic asking your
grandson how his sexual experience went
sorry i just thought maybe i could have
repeated sex with the horse machine
without it becoming armageddon you and
me both morty
you and me both oh sh did i say that out
loud
what did you do i got out of your eye
line
the show man you can't beat me you
didn't bring a woman that could kick box
totally fair but also kickboxist my
hands are tied
form a perimeter protect that egg at all
costs or
and this might be crazy shoot the egg
and destroy it
you slept with my daughter i did oh [ __ ]
i did gedestiality
you come to the kingdom of chuds for
forgiveness
um technically rick and morty were
kidnapped to the kingdom of kahuds so
they didn't come here willingly to do
anything chads don't forgive humans
chuds eat humans this is out there even
for us
it is not right i i love you too
princess ponieta
lying where did you get all that
and why aren't they spraying it on the
egg take three steps back amazing
jonathan
show proposes the idea that the
president of the united states would
know who the
amazing jonathan is that's nancy reagan
this [ __ ]
i would say that none of this hopping
from sperm to sperm should work but
really we could just say that about the
entirety of this show
mom i promise to use condoms even when
it's butt stuff okay we have a lot to
talk about tonight waiting this long to
talk to your kid about butt stuff
always be honest sometimes it will hurt
people
sometimes it will help but always be
honest
sports illustrated kathy ireland is
making a lot of sense i don't think we
appreciated sports illustrated cathy
island enough in her heyday
and that's 100 of sin a giant incest
baby in space
still makes more sense than 2001 i guess
do i like this show may i do not
wait who the [ __ ] is that i am the borg
they're heading for vegas
vegas baby vegas where's your costume
this is my costume i'm a homicidal
maniac we
got a baby a science baby
what a cute little pink bunny rabbit
the langoliers don't don't even exist
you just made them up